for live local now good afternoon thanks
so much for joining us at 4 i'm kirstjen
joyce and i'm brian loftis an explosion
injures employees working at a concrete
facility in boulder city as dozens of
emergency personnel rush to that scene
victoria saha now joins us from boulder
city with the very latest on the
incident
this is as close as we can get to the
site of the explosion the damage was so
severe it blew out windows in the main
building the monday morning explosion
caused dozens of employees to evacuate
their job sited armor rock polymer
concrete it was a pretty massive
explosion deputy fire chief of boulder
city greg chester says the damage was so
bad his team had to take extra
precautions before thinking about
stepping foot inside initially we didn't
even go in
we just kind of
surveyed wait until we had enough
personnel here
once we did and we had a hazmat team go
in they were able to
size up the situation a total of six
employees were injured one of them with
significant burns from the blast based
on the number of injuries we had to
initiate an ems strike team the massive
destruction had about 45 ems and fire
personnel on site right now the building
inspector needs to come by and see if it
is safe enough to return and work in
still no word on what caused this
explosion reporting in boulder city
victoria saha live local now
osha is working with the clark county
building inspector to determine what
caused the blast